The joe rogan experience.
It's amazing that you were like,
you're so entrenched in them.
Yeah.
You seem like a pretty,
pretty together dude.
I think so.
I mean,
I'm,
kids changed me.
I mean,
I got,
I got two young,
I got a two year old in a,
in a five month old and my wife changed me.
I mean,
I never thought I'd get married.
I was living,
when I got on hoarders,
I was living on a buddy's couch.
I was cleaning up Shit for 12 bucks an hour,
literally shoveling shit for 12 bucks an hour.
And anybody who would hire me,
look a dog,
like people's dogs know people's houses.
I'd go into a hoarder house and clean up their shit for 12 bucks an hour before
the show even.
Yeah.
I was cleaning houses for four years.
I hit when I hit rock bottom,
I mean,
I literally lost everything.
I was living on a buddy's couch for 200 bucks a month and I couldn't come up
with 200 bucks the third month.
He was like,
dude,
you know,
you're,
we're 30 man.
Like you gotta you gotta do something,
man.
I remember,
I'll never forget.
I mean that's like something I'll Pi guys.
I,
my 30th birthday I call,
I was engaged to another girl and I realized they're like,
my life is a fucking joke.
Like I can't pull her into this.
I'm not,
I got no business being married.
And so I called off the wedding like a month before Husky getting married.
Wow.
And it was,
that was a hard decision.
And I was living on my buddy's couch and I was my 30th birthday,
which you know,
is a milestone in your head.
And I said to my mom and my mom's like,
what do you want?
It's been a hell of a year.
And I was like,
I need a pair of running shoes.
And I couldn't afford,
I was trying to run a marathon that year and I couldn't affair for a pair of
shoes to run.
I didn't have no money.
I would like a hundred grand in credit cards.
And I mean,
it was scary.
So I started cleaning up old ladies' houses.
Wow.
And how'd you get that job?
Like,
how did I,
my dad died?
The biggest thing,
important thing of my life from me with my dad dying when I was 24 and that
changed my life and he,
my dad,
I was a fucking asshole.
I was just a piece of shit.
All I cared about was drinking,
gambling and him,
women,
all three great things.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean my twenties were really fun.
It sounds like you had a good time and I lost [inaudible].
Did you stop at a blast?
I really be talking to a guy who I spend a good deal of my youth and pool halls.
Yeah,
so you,
I mean the hustle.
I was hustling man paddocks on a regular basis.
But you very,
very common.
Yeah.
I mean for me,
I didn't,
I hadn't honed my hustle in the right place.
I'm still a hustler.
I'm just doing it on TV in a positive way.
I never changed who I am.
I'm just able,
I've learned I'm able to make more money in a positive way than I am in a
negative way.
How people don't talk.
Like I talk,
they don't say the things I say and I've learned.
Just being brutally honest is the best hustle there is.
How did you get into this environment?
Where you around like gamblers and how did,
how did all this happen?
Oh Man.
I just,
I love,
at the first time I went to casino I fell in love with it,
man.
How old were you a college?
This Guy George.
So that's when he became a gamble.
Yannick [inaudible],
this Guy George Rome,
and he had Tourette's.
Really cool dude.
He was a very confident guy.
He had Tourette's,
but he didn't give a shit.
It was like your problem that he had Tourette's.
Wow.
That's awesome.
Very confident guy.
And so I was like very attracted.
I was like,
man,
this is a cool fucking guy.
Like he put it on you.
He did not care that he had Tourette's and he would get the hottest chicks at
school.
He's a really awesome,
confident guy.
And I,
my dad always told me,
he's like,
you're never gonna be the looking guy.
You'll never be the hardest working guy.
You gotta be the most confident cause it's like that's your only in like you got
no other value added thing broke you off.
No,
he just was honest.
He's like,
you know,
you're not going to be rich.
You're not going to be rich.
You're not going to be,
you know,
here's a rule.
You ain't got a big dig.
It is what it is.
And my dad got it mad,
mad women.
I mean he got,
and he was so ugly,
but he just loved him.
He knew how to,
he talked.
Honest,
he talked on us and he treated them like he treated with respect and as a woman.
And so I learned a lot from him.
But when my dad died,
I went to this little place called comfort zone camp.
It's a camp for kids that have lost their dads.
And so I was,
you know,
we helped to build the La camp and my wife and I did my eye,
but I met her there.
And uh,
but we helped build these camps for these kids at all.
Their dads had buy a diet and drive bys.
So you meet all these 12 year old kids that are going in,
you know they're getting recruited by gangs already cause their dads have
already there.
There are 23 year old dads,
you know,
had been killed 25 zero we did.
So we learn,
I mean I just,
grief was a huge part early on and so for me,
like when I got Adam,
I really rock bottom and I realize it's time to get going where I figured that
out,
the doing good versus doing bad was at this camp.
I would,
I got addicted to that camp.
I volunteered every single weekend and I would just make it go away for three
nights and hanging out these kids and that's when I got my new addiction was
then wow.
It changed my life.
That place changed when I met my wife there.
I came up with new business,
my business clutter cleaner.
I came up with it.
They're helping these kids.
I met a lot of great women and met my wife there.
So I mean I wouldn't have what I have.
How did you pull yourself out of the gambling spar?
You said you found you.
So I ran like a fucking chicken man.
I mean,
I got my ass kicked by a bookie and I owed 40 grand the night before I had $10
left to my name.
I knew I owed this bookie when it was,
I mean I think it was 40 grand and it was a lot.
I knew I only had $10 in my pocket and my girlfriend was waiting for me.
I was in Lake Tahoe.
She was waiting for me at the top of the hill up in heaven.
Lee and I was gambling all night.
I can't hide Tendai what,
$5 in my mind I thought I had $5 at the end of the night and I was like,
I better put this down.
I got to get a cab ride home.
So I was giving up at $5 to my name and I owed 42 the booking.
Yeah.
Which for a 24 year old kid and make it not making that as a lot of money.
And so I put the chip down.
Lost,
came out.
I had no,
my last,
my last dollar came out and had nothing and it was like I got a fucking problem.
And so I was looking at the cabby and he's like the guy that drove me back every
night and he was like,
he looked at me and was like,
I got no money man.
So I started walking up hill five miles uphill to the ski resort.
Tom's a very uh,
awesome isolating place.
So it was a five mile,
it's inclined roads.
We went up and I'm walking up this thing and he came and picked me up and he was
like,
dude,
you got to,
you got to get your life together man.
You've got gotta quit gambling and everyone is,
and at that point I was still judging people and I was like looking at this,
I was like,
this poor stupid cab driver knew God knows what happened to him,
but I was totally judging him yet he's saving me,
he's picking me up.
And so I'm still treating this guy like in my mind like a piece of shit.
And he picks me up.
He dropped me off and I'm like,
can I give you anything?
Can I,
can I it?
He's like,
dude,
just stop gambling.
And he looked at me like,
just fucking stop.
That's when they just off.
Well,
and I called my mom the next morning and she was like,
you're on your own.
So then I went,
I called the bookie and I was like,
I don't know what to do man.
I don't have the money.
And I mean,
this was like a movie.
He's like,
no worries man.
Everything's gonna be fine.
We'll work it out.
What do you have?
I was like,
I might be able to scrounge up $1,000.
He goes,
no worries.
Come on down.
I'll meet you down this afternoon.
So I was like,
this isn't like movies at all.
This is great.
This,
we're going to work it out.
And I went down,
he took the thousand bucks and he'd beat the shit out of me,
broke my nose.
I totally was just clueless.
And he,
he just,
he broke my nose and beat the shit out of me.
That was my rock bottom.
And I was like,
what the fuck am I going to do?
So I called around,
I call it an old boss,
and I told him,
what did,
my mom had already said,
you're on your own.
Find a legal way out.
And that was the night where I put a lot of dumb shit on the board mean I was
like,
alright,
I'll just be a prostitute or I'll do whatever.
Like I was like,
Oh,
you know,
I was like,
I can be mentally strong.
I can figure this out.
And I was lying to myself saying,
Wow.
And so ended up an old boss got me a job in Chicago when he goes,
when can you get,
this was a Tuesday night.
And he goes,
when can you get there?
And I was like,
Friday.
He goes,
you start Friday,
they're going to pay off the bookie,
but you're gonna have to work for a year to pay it.
They're going to take it out,
peace out every night.
And I was like,
great,
thank you.
And I literally,
my buddy,
I didn't have money to get home,
so I had to play poker that night.
Bar 50 bucks from a buddy and play one enough money playing poker to get gas
money.
Oh my God.
And that's why I drove home and I never gambled again.
Really?
You just quit?
I quit a ran away and I still run away.
I still run away today.
I just don't get,
I mean like this is the worst week for me.
The first,
uh,
the NCAA tournament.
Oh.
Killing me.
Killing me,
man.
Oh my God.
I love it.
Do you still watch it?
Oh yeah.
Love it.
Oh Wow.
No,
I just don't do the sheets.
I delete all the emails.
I just can't do the sheets.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So you just love that kind of limited in every day.
I,
you know,
I don't sort of,
well you have a handle on it.
I think gambling eight years,
I don't really,
yeah,
I'm lucky.
I mean my kids are just wearing me out and I don't really have the effort for
that kind of stuff anymore.
Does it still draw you though?
Every once in a while I get that itch.
Yeah.
Every once in a while I'll get that.
Like I had it this year.
I had a really bad itch and I had a flight to Vegas to do a hoarder's episode
and it wasn't even in Vegas.
I just had a three hour layover and I was like,
fuck yeah,
I'm going downtown.
And I got excited and I hadn't had that itch in a long time.
Like I can drink,
I can smoke,
I can do whatever because I can walk,
go away.
I can't walk away from a table.
That's my weakness.
I don't know how to walk away if I have a dollar or 10 grand fucking blow your
special brain chemistry,
whatever it is in Europe.
For me,
that's my gambling comes up.
You just being loved.
That's my ultimate way of shoving it to the man and like,
I'm better than you.
I can do this.
And I know it's,
for me,
it's the self worth thing.
I was looking for self worth.
So again,
but how do you get so forth that it began for me?
That's where it went,
man.
That,
I mean for you you might get,
I mean,
where do you get yourself worth?
I don't Dunno.
I get it.
Try not to think about it.
Yeah,
my new thing now it's like I really know that I'm making a difference on these
podcasts,
so I dig that.
I'm starting to get it.
That's where I'm getting my rough go.
Five decisions away,
five decisions of where and when and what is essentially,
what does it well,
it's about,
it just recounts all my mistakes.
Over the last 15 years I was doing a hoarder's where in New York City where this
guy had a mass,
he had an acre in Brooklyn,
a massive property in Brooklyn.
This guy inherited it from his dad and it was,
had about six feet of bicycles all the way through the yard.
So an acre at six feet high.
Think of the metal,
the value of that metal was probably a hundred grand and metal and he had a bum
living in his yard.
So inside the hoard,
there was a bum living there and that was one of the things we had to clean up.
We have to get rid of the bum.
So I was literally,
I mean this was two years ago,
I'm sitting here in,
uh,
in Brooklyn hanging out with this bum.
His name is Gregory.
I'll never forget him.
And I was like,
and this is the cool thing about hoarders.
I get to meet Delis dudes.
And I was like,
all right Greg,
your head,
you end up here man.
Cause he had,
I mean,
he had a bunch of,
like a 40 ounces,
a bunch of these magnum condoms.
And so I was like,
fuck yeah,
this guy's getting more acid than I am.
And he lives in a chicken shack.
You know,
he was huffing.
I didn't realize it was hot.
He was just huffing gasoline,
huffing gasoline.
Yeah.
Condoms.
They would fill up the condoms and then,
uh,
with the fumes and thought he was getting asked.
I didn't really just trying to get high.
She kicked me in the nuts.
A job that must keep you grounded in,
in like other possibilities of reality,
not necessarily your reality,
but the pony was ever in this.
That's the,
that's what we came with five decisions away because,
uh,
back to it,
we need finished it,
that bum sitting in the yard.
I asked him how he got there and he goes,
oh,
I was a stockbroker.
And I was like,
get outta here.
Whoa.
And I'm like,
he's there,
he's full of shit or this is real.
So I went with it,
you know,
and I was like,
what do you mean you were striking?
He goes,
I was a stockbroker and a girl broke my heart and they go,
you're telling me you're living in this guy's yard because a girl broke your
heart.
He was willing got addicted to crack too.
But the girl broke my heart and I was like,
yeah,
the crack plan.
Have something to do with it.
Yeah.
But he lived in a fucking shack.
And so I looked at the camera and I go,
I guess we are all really s five decisions away from shitting in a bucket.
Yeah.
Wow.
And that just stuck.
And when I said that people ran with it,
and I'm clearly five,
had many five decisions away from shitting in a bucket.
And I mean,
couple things different happened and I in my life could've been totally
different.
It might not be any five,
it could be one if it's a bad one.
[inaudible].